c'est en 2014 que jean françois roberge
a été élu pour la première fois député
la cac
mais avant c'est ici dans cette école
primaire de saint basile le grand que le
nouveau ministre de l'éducation a
travaillé il était enseignant cinquième
année c'est spécial de penser que mon
collègue va devenir mon patron françois
girard a travaillé avec jean françois
roberge pendant deux ans les enfants
sont importants produits comme collègue
d'un professeur qui était engagé le
professeur qui qui aimait stimuler ses
élèves jean-françois vos s'investit
personnellement il va donner tout ce qui
peut ça c'est sûr et certain
lorsqu'il fait jamais rien à moitié
cette enseignante aussi la bien connue
c'est elle qui le remplace depuis qu'il
a quitté l'école très dynamique jouait
de la guitare dans les corridors c'est
ce que je trouve bien avec jean france
passé qui veut faire avancer les choses
jean françois roberge a été enseignant
au niveau primaire pendant 17 ans
pendant ses études il a milité à la
fédération étudiante universitaire du
québec
il est aussi un des fondateurs de
l'ancienne association de défense des
jeunes enseignants du québec frédéric
lapointe l'a connu alors qu'il était
étudiant à l'université
c'est quelqu'un de très déterminé il
n'est pas quelqu'un qui est un grand
amour pour les syndicats d'enseignants
ça s'est vu l'association défense des
jeunes enseignants y est un promoteur de
l'ordre professionnel des enseignants
est donc maintenant qu'il est dans le
poste de pilotage ce seront des
questions intéressantes à suivre
il connaît bien le système de
l'éducation il a même écrit un livre ici
on réinventait l'école un livre dans
lequel il propose d'instaurer la
maternelle 4 ans tous les enfants
d'ajouter des ressources pour dépister
les élèves en difficulté et d'augmenter
l'âge obligatoire de fréquentation
scolaire
à 18 ans des idées qui se retrouve
actuellement dans le programme de la cac
pour une bonne chance là c'est sûr que
du pain sur la planche
il en ira pas j'espère que ça va nous
amener plus de services
et puis plus dyke pour nos élèves en
difficulté c'est quelqu'un qui voit
reconnaître le terrain ça garantissent
pas par exemple une efficacité on a
juste savoir qu'est ce que ces fonds
santé quatre ans après avoir quitté sa
salle de classe le nouveau ministre de
l'éducation fait face à des défis de
taille
compte tenu de tous les changements
qu'il propose ici jean philippe robien à
radio canada montréal